I'm gonna have it all I think people are
not fully aware of some of the risks and
the challenges we face there are of
course moments of great person listen I
have my days optimistic Monday
pessimistic Tuesday we're never going to
say aha we've achieved justice nirvana
is here never are we going to get
perfect justice we'd never get people
agreeing on what perfect justice is
we've been through more than 10 years of
very low economic volatility bars it's
hard to believe that this low volatility
environment will continue indefinitely
and it may even be ending as we speak
you'll be realistic for us to expect to
live to say age 120g wouldn't it be nice
to live in elizabethan in Elizabethan
times probably wouldn't like the lice
and the body odor of the early death of
the small pox scars Renaissance of
Chinese culture and Chinese history in
fact the 21st century might be the new
Tang Dynasty there's a danger that if we
devote too much time and energy to
worrying about climate change over a
hundred years we could lose sight of our
ability to destroy ourselves within five
years troublemakers and anarchists
listen carefully to what they're saying
if you held a gun to my head forsman a
prediction I think we're headed towards
on you know 20 30 years of incredible
chaos and turmoil and then at the tail
end of a lil emerge with a world better
than any weeks now imagine